hey we're in the tank with the
battleships in five six feet long hair
how they actually have these turrets and
give it around then shoot these little
balls at the other couch so what are we
looking at here so this is I guess you
could say it's a hacked PlayStation
controller but it has its own circuit I
replaced the circuit board on it it has
a it's running a zigbee transceiver
module just like this on the inside and
this is the target designation so that's
what turns the turrets this is what
turns the trip this actually tells the
ship what direction the target is in and
then these buttons are so instead of
just firing straight you know if you've
got it right here and you put it
straight off to the left and you tell it
that it's actually at about six feet it
won't just go straight out it'll
actually turn the barrels in it
converges on the target now look this is
the this is the current state-of-the-art
radio this is a thousand-dollar RC
computerized radio that controller makes
this radio obsolete that's the next
generation you're seeing it for the
first time right here this takes our sea
of boating or whatever you want to use
it for from NRCS the hobby into a gaming
sport
that's the difference right at you okay
we exchange a shot
yeah can watch this ready
Oh